any sufficiently advanced technologies
in station magic like to have dr. Judson
Brewer with us today I'm into the
impossible podcast all the way from from
Rhode Island I believe you're in Rhode
Island and right now is that right Jeff
we live in Massachusetts yes I work in
at Providence the place right behind you
yes that's right so those of you
watching the video will see my alma
mater where I spent many years getting
my PhD not becoming a real doctor like
dr. Judd but becoming a doctor
nonetheless a philosophical doctor and
it's a great treat to talk to you you
know I only found out about you probably
about a year year and a half ago and
since then I've been kind of one of your
chief evangelist on the west coast at
least and we're gonna get into all your
great work and especially your book
because books are a big part of this
podcast I started doing the the pandemic
podcasting which I trademark copyrighted
and internationally patented a few
months ago just you know when I started
to seem like the world was changing for
authors such as yourself and myself and
and I noticed you started to do
something really useful and wonderfully
gracious for the world and I want to to
ask how that that projects going so
first we can in Treme be you can
introduce yourself who are you what do
you do and then I want to turn to this
wonderful service that you've been
providing for me and thousands probably
hundreds of thousands of people around
the world sure I'm Judd Broome the
director of research and innovation at
Brown University's mindfulness Center
I'm an associate professor in both the
behavioral and social sciences in the
School of Public Health and in
psychiatry in the School of Medicine I
also founded a startup called mine
sciences and so that's that's who I am
but I love Alice in Wonderland says who
in the world am i ah that is the great
puzzle that's right and I've been
following your your many podcast your
TED talk which by now has been seen by
over 10 million people around the world
on different sites I want to touch base
with you in addition to
the stuff you do as an academic you're
also doing a lot of what we call
outreach and public education can you
comment on some of the things you've
been doing most particularly I don't
know why a professor and his or her
right mind would add to their office
hours you know I always say being a
professor is the hardest three hour a
week job in the world now you're making
me look bad judge so tell me tell us
about your office hours and your in your
daily dose that you've been doing in
March and April on on mindfulness and
anxiety prevention yeah so as a
psychiatrist I've seen a lot of really
good information go out around physical
you know illness like how to prevent the
spread of coronavirus how did you know
eat healthy things like that but I
haven't seen a lot on mental health
mental health issues and mental wellness
and so I really felt motivated I was
inspired seeing you know others you know
you certainly haven't innovated a
patient since I was a resident so you
know me me jumping in volunteering in
the ICU is probably not the best idea
but I but I can certainly help with some
of the mental health side of things so I
was actually just inspired to start
putting together short you know 5 to 10
minute YouTube videos on a daily basis
because there's so much related to
mental health that is really coming to
the fore here and it kind of it was it
all was seeded by a New York Times
article that I wrote on you know like
why we get anxious
based on these fear responses and how
social contagion and all that plays a
role and so people's at all you know
that's it's a great article can you know
what else can you give us and it just
turned out there's a lot more everything
from guilt and shame to you know to
getting addicted to the news feeds
absolutely an addiction science that you
study has been really effectively used
by again probably tens or hundreds of
thousands of people around the world
whether they know it or not because I
think some of the some of the stuff that
you're known for in particular the habit
loop which we'll get into and and your
book the craving mind which we'll get
into those
those have really kind of brought to the
forefront not just a philosophy but
actually actionable tools tactics
techniques that people can use to do
things like quit smoking be less
intimately connected to their social
media devices in my case lose weight I
dropped actually 5 pounds from my double
chin to my stomach thanks to you and
very no actually its I do use your
products your eat right now app is very
healthy to maintain health during this
pandemic period first because the
podcast is often about talking about
books I want to talk about you know kind
of the inspiration because I like many
people do judge books by their covers
and I want to talk about what they
covered is in line and the meaning of
the title what does that really mean
that the craving mind you know I the I
mean I realized how addicted I was to
things when I started studying addiction
you know in the joke you've probably
heard this research is me search yeah
buddy
in fact I started meditating beginning
of medical school was doing my PhD is
actually in immunology I shifted to
neuroscience during residency I retooled
there and so I was just kind of study
you know studying molecular mechanisms
of the immune system and things like
that and going along and when I was
learning you know in my psychiatry
rotations in Medical School and then in
residency I started learning more about
you know mental health and where we
struggle and where we fall down I am you
know honestly in psychiatry there aren't
a ton of great medications out there to
help people and so I was really inspired
to start asking these questions like
well what are we missing what what
doesn't work and it turns out that that
started intersecting with my own
personal mindfulness practice where I
was noticing wait a minute a lot of this
stuff that I was learning from Buddhist
psychology could it be applied today and
you know decade or so later after doing
a bunch of the neuroscience research in
clinical studies I'm I was just I was
just inspired to write this book because
I realized there a gazillion
ways that were were were addicted and
then we have craving and so yeah I think
the first half or two-thirds of my book
is actually titled with different ways
that were addicted you know addicted to
technology addicted to self addicted to
distraction addicted to love you know my
one of my personal addictions that that
manifested quite a bit in college and so
the craving mine was just the way to
kind of bring all of that together in
kind of one common theme or what they
called the mule that carries the story
the threat of a story through a book
yeah and I want to talk specifically
about the cover itself
tell us about the title of the book how
that came about and the very simple kind
of iconography that you use and the
subtitle - yeah cigarettes - smartphones
- love how we can break that habit
I think the thread there I was I was
blown away by these common mechanisms
where you know we can be addicted to
cigarettes in the same way we can be
addicted to eating in the same way we
can be addicted to - romantic love so
that's where the subtitle came from okay
uh-huh
and the cover of the cover of the book
talked us through that what was that the
meaning behind it perhaps and the reason
for the design elements that you use and
that I'll also show the audio book
because I read it listen to it the audio
book and I always like to do that and
we'll give away a copy obviously to
people that read the listen to it on
iTunes and leave a review of this
episode so yeah talk about the cover
design the audio book in particular I'm
going to get that up you know has has a
little bit more of the the subtitle
elements that go into it so it shows of
the brain and it shows the the various
little icons pointing to different
addictions that people have yeah yeah
but the title itself Judd what about the
title itself talk us through that yeah
that's really all the all-encompassing
theme where it's really our mind that
starts craving stuff whether it's
cigarettes or smartphones or love or
distraction or whatever and it's not you
know it's not about the thing itself
it's not the cigarette itself cigarettes
certainly have addictive elements but
it's really the mind they get so it's
why all of these things mm-hmm
and craving is built-in would you say
into the human mind because of the
different biological pathways that
course through our genetics or is it
something more malleable that's
epigenetically perhaps imprinted by the
environment Emillio the culture even
that we grow up in I would say some of
both
so certainly these urges to act drive
our very basic survival mechanisms you
know so you know it's these mechanisms
are set up to help us remember where
food is and also to remember we're
dangerous or we can avoid it and it's
interesting dopamine firing happens when
we get an unexpected reward right you
know so you can imagine you're wandering
around the savannah suddenly you find a
food source your brain fires this
dopamine off it says hey remember this
plate so you can come back here tomorrow
and get some more food same thing you
know you see this average it's higher
and you're like oh it's danger over here
remember this don't come back here too
far but that dopamine firing doesn't
happen every time we get to that food
source because we've already learned it
right that firing shifts from receiving
the reward you know from finding that
food to anticipating so that dopamine
firing goes to it says hey you know get
off your butt go get the food so it
motivates us to action once we've
learned the behavior and so that's
actually where the craving comes in so
there's a that's a very basic learning
mechanism yet you know I wouldn't say it
suggests well great example cigarettes
do not help our survival but we can
actually learn to crave cigarettes in
the same way that we you know that these
mechanisms help us find food you know we
but through a very different mechanism
so typically when what I've seen in our
studies the typical onset of smoking is
13 years of age so these are pretty
young people that start smoking and
typically it's because of things like
they want to be cool at school or
they're rebelling against their parents
or whatever you know they want to fit in
so they'll actually overcome the
aversive nassif smoking a cigarette
because nicotine is actually a toxin
so they feel sick the first time they
smoke but they'll actually they'll fight
against that and then ironically become
addicted to the nicotine itself because
they'll go through withdrawal physically
and then you know though they'll
reinforce that process I had a patient
who came in he wanted to quit smoking
after 40 years and he had reinforced
that pathway 293 thousand times right so
this is how much it can get looped in so
this is where genetics play together
with epigenetics and also play together
with with basic cue reinforcement
paradigms now I want to get into
meditation I want to talk about you know
the focus and your work is very much on
is very much on kind of stimulating
curiosity and hacking the loops
themselves and short-circuiting them
before that they get to be dangerous
addictions obviously some things you
know might be less addictive or less
less detrimental say you know nicotine
is probably higher up on the list of
things of you know potential dangers
because it's linked to smoking then say
coffee might be I'm hoping because some
coffee every every couple of minutes but
but but I want to talk first before we
get into that there's been a
proliferation as you must know of
meditation apps and books and TED talks
and and approaches and and everything
from you know from seeing recently on my
audible I saw get your meditation your
daily meditation from Puff Daddy and I
thought you know is this the sign you
know have we really been nothing against
Puff Daddy I'm sure you know he has an
MD and a PhD also not just kidding but
but you know there are these books by
you know Dan Harris his brother as I
understand Sam Harris not their brothers
but but they they have these apps and
they have these but and you've actually
been in 10% happier even featured on us
and Dan Harris's and his app and and
even on online on his podcast what
separates this approach from those
approaches and you know if meditation
you know just being a little in a
provocative if men
is as powerful then then should there be
one modality of employing it that's
superior to the others I mean we all
want to be in better fitness we no I
don't think anyone really wants to smoke
I mean it's not they're better hobbies
you can pick up and smoking so how is it
that there's so many different
applicators it's just a sign of you know
people jumping on the same bad bandwagon
that you hacked many years ago or is
there something to these in a variety of
different approaches yeah you know I
think we can learn both from history and
modernity which is that historically
even if you look it's like Buddhist
psychology schools for example there are
three main schools that are survived to
a common day you know our two current
day like there's this Tara
you know that's considered more than
Vipassana some describe it as that or
Insight Meditation there's n there's
there's Tibetan meditation and they
really have different flavors of
teaching you know the same core
teachings but you know was with some
slight you know with some differences
and I think that actually appeals to
different proclivities that people have
so for example you don't want to over
generalize but the tera vaada Buddhism
is more kind of analytically
scientifically oriented so a lot and
that's what I got most interested in and
so that I was drawn to that as compared
to Zen or the term you know or the
Tibetan or the Vajrayana schools so I
think there's a you know there's not a
one-size-fits-all for anything this goes
from everything from diets to exercise
to meditation programs so that's one
thing I think to keep in mind
historically now in modernity I agree I
think it's just lots of people are
jumping on the bandwagon they're like oh
I can record a guided meditation or I
liked meditation so I'm gonna do it you
know I'm gonna do my own and it's not
you know throw some money at something
and you can have a nap so I think
there's a lot of that going on I and you
know they're in there's a wide range of
quality in terms of some of these
programs so for example the 10% happier
app has you know they bring in very
senior
in skilled meditation teachers as part
of their platform
I'm ARS takes a slightly different
approach than all of these basic ones
which is you know we're we're not
actually aiming at like a general
meditation app there are plenty of those
out there but we're focusing on helping
people with specific problems so you
know if you smoke or if you stress eater
overeat or if you have anxiety you know
that's where we're focusing because
we're zooming right into the
neurobiological mechanisms and targeting
those specifically and it just turns out
that my lab has studied that mindfulness
actually works very well for these types
of things so we're taking more of an
evidence-based approach so for those of
you watching I've switched my background
this is a quiz for the professor
professor dr. Judd and do you know what
we're looking at in the background here
uh it looks like somebody's richly
decorated living room this is allegedly
Freud's Freud's couch it's beyond that
at least that's what the internet told
me when I stole this picture well I see
stat it busts of the Buddha in the
background yeah yeah so that's what made
me doubtful but but there's some old
looking books anyway that the way that I
want to make now is into the practice
both both in you know psychiatric
training in in graduate school in
medical school but but also to you know
the popularization of this we just spoke
about in your own work I recall Freud
saying something to the effect that
there are certain groups or cultures
that are just generically are resistant
to psychotherapy so you know I'm Jewish
and we're not one of those groups right
we're famously you know addicted to
addiction recovery and neuroses
we're neurotic about our lack of
neuroses if we don't have them but but
in in in reality our is it true do you
believe it's true what for it said that
there are some cultures that are
fundamentally just you know will be
resistant to psychoanalysis and if so is
that also true of meditation or some
people just cannot meditate cannot use
these tools yeah it's a good question I
it's in I probably agree I have to think
more about this but I agree that there
are going to be some people that are
resistant and especially if you take a
specific type of psychotherapy like
psychoanalysis there going to be people
that are going to be resistant to that
interestingly we see and a fair number
of different types of psychotherapy is
out there that might indicate that's
having you know more personalized
approaches they're gonna be they're
gonna span that one-size-fits-all
category and so here if Freud said you
know there are people resistant to
psychoanalysis sure
are there people resistant to
psychotherapy sure I basically resistant
to psychotherapy I and that may you know
that can indicate a bunch of different
things but with the number of different
types of psychotherapy is out there
you're more likely to find matches for
people here I would say I with
meditation I've had many many people say
that they you know they can't meditate
or they don't like meditating or
whatever we've actually looked at but I
would say that I have not met a single
person who's not interested in how their
own mind works
so that's a different question and I
think if you approach it that way where
you know I don't I didn't know how my
mind works I don't even know it in in
medical school I didn't note in
residency I didn't have a good sense for
that maybe I didn't do my 50 years of
psychoanalysis four days a week or
whatever I'm but it'd be a little late
at that point anyway so here you know I
think some of the early Buddhist
psychology is actually really insightful
in the sense that it really teaches us
how our minds work and interestingly it
has a very strong correlation with with
the modern concepts around reinforcement
learning we wrote a paper on on this
showing that the ancient Buddhist
psychology lines up beautifully with
reinforcement learning with positive and
negative reinforcement and they they
came up with this before paper was even
invented so here you know I think if we
phrase it from the
effective of who's interested in how
their mind works everybody raises their
hand because not only whether it's a
curiosity side of things or whether it's
just helping them function hmm everybody
wants to know something about how their
mind works so that's if we approach it
from that perspective I think this is
somewhat Universal I mean I'm sure
there's gonna be the the mind aight what
would you what's the equivalent of a
Luddite who's not interested
how their own mind works there's gonna
be somebody but that's gonna be at the
very far end of the bell curve in terms
of yeah let's get into technology then
so yeah you're talking about but you
know 4,000 year old 5,000 year old
technology so in addition to the
technology that could be enhanced from
learning about how the mind works and
the tools that are used you were on 60
minutes with Anderson Cooper a few about
a year or two ago and and you're going
through you're putting him through an
MRI and fMRI and and he's meditating
he's thinking about something stressful
you know his ratings are dropping by
half a percent or something and then all
of a sudden you make him start
meditating he drops in to use his
language he drops into meditation and
we'll roll some b-roll footage showing
him in that and it's this huge
contraption with gel and you're
squirting gel into 128 electrodes and
and now you know I've got this thing
here it's called a muse headband and I
also you know I'm gonna techie right so
I'm an anti Luddite and I've got the
oculus and I've got earbuds and I've got
this I've got an aura ring and I've got
I was shocked here's my aura ring you
know he came and see it I've got the
next generation stealth you know it's
completely invisible transparent first
of all do you buy into any of these
things that I waste you know 200 bucks
unless you use headset or is it just a
placebo I there was a guy from The Wall
Street though I'll give you a short
answer which is look for science
that's my biases toward science and you
it's actually hard to find any research
showing definitive evidence for any of
these things I think they're nice start
and can get people curious and
interested in things but there's
actually a Wall Street Journal reporter
who called me because he had mastered
the muse
mm-hmm and he I think he wanted a quote
from a scientist to write his article
and you know we talked for a bit and he
said it just jumped I said can I come
visit your lab and he drove up from New
York City like that night and the next
morning we put him in our in our EEG
neurofeedback rig where he could watch
his own brain activity in real time and
we blinded him because it's really not
literally but we we did a blinded
experiment yep so that he could not be
biased because it's so easy to fool
ourselves you know I think Richard
Fineman used to say you know we're the
easiest to fool
he always said he said the first
principle is you must not fool yourself
and you're the easiest person to fool
and I've kind of I've kind of wondered
on Twitter you know what was his second
principle you know this is the first one
but yeah I'm good that's right that's
about confirmation bias right yeah yeah
totally so long story short this guy you
know was able to move the signal and it
moved in the opposite direction of all
of our studies of experienced meditators
and then and then we unblinded amidship
said you know that's actually in the
opposite direction of what we what we
see and i he had told me the day before
that he practiced he practiced chi gong
for a long time I said so I said just do
your Qigong practice mentally because
that has elements I think that are very
similar to mindfulness he did that and
it immediately dropped they've moved
into the direction that we find when
people are effortlessly aware so he
ended up writing a very mixed article in
Wall Street Journal have to link to that
I nailed the muse you know this I got
that third eye on the first try yo you
know so they're you know I'm friendly
with the folks at Muse they never tell
me what their algorithm is it's a trade
secret I think so I don't know what
they're doing but I haven't seen any
studies that they published showing that
this lines up you know definitively with
anything I'm sure they have some signal
that they're going by but I just I would
encourage folks just to be careful
you know when they buy consumer products
because you know also the electrodes
across your forehead
it may hopefully they've control for
this but the biggest signal you're gonna
get is from your frontalis muscle right
yeah I think that that is actually being
monitor you know if I go like really
grit my teeth or you know do the thing I
like about it is that it's not a guided
meditation you know it's it's you have
wonderful guided meditations but I think
just like cross-training you know I say
it's like cross-training in your brain
you know you can do different different
styles guided meta you know
loving-kindness you can do in and and I
want to get into that because I think I
think for the listeners to the into the
impossible podcast you know we're kind
of tech forward we're kind of interested
in future technology like our namesakes
or arthur c clarke you know kind of
provided a role model in many ways not
in all but but certainly in terms of
thinking about the future and using
science fiction as a way to kind of hack
the future and pre-game and your
prefrontal cortex and you talked a lot
about this mental models you don't use
the physics term for it but it's called
a Gedanken experiment a thought
experiment but you do mention the
thought experiment concept but
physicists know that as Gedanken
experiments and i do wonder you know why
why wouldn't it be possible to have a
technological input unless it might be
that you know there's something about
meditation what's the first step in many
meditations it's gonna close your eyes
but then you have these other
technologies like the oculus you know VR
headsets you know and you don't get into
this too much but you you know it was
kind of written I think a little bit
before the onslaught of AR and VR but is
there a place for it I mean can I
imagine having a muse headband with
goggles with ears with ear and then like
tiny haptic electric shocks you know if
I stop think you know like we need some
negative reinforcement to we can only be
positive right I so I think that's a I
think it's a technology absolutely plays
a role and we you know we people can see
from the Anderson Cooper video there is
you know we're using we're already
starting to move from fMRI to eg
neurofeedback where we can get specific
signal from people deep in people's
brains which wasn't possible
ten years ago and we're even moving from
28 leads down to 32 leads or so so I
think the technology is improving
rapidly enough that we can see you know
we're gonna see this thing happen you
know in the next couple of years and I
and we've done a bunch of studies
specifically to map out these different
brain regions and how they line up with
meditation all this we published a bunch
of papers on it so the idea is can we
get a technology that really does line
up with the elements of meditation and
also importantly I think feedback is
only good if it can teach us something
about ourselves so we can we're not
dependent on the technology so I think
technology is a great way to teach us
something but if we become dependent on
Punnett is that really that great of a
thing so here we found something really
interesting from some of the neuro
phenomena logic studies that we've done
which were around when we looked at
people's experience so for example
there's this network of brain regions
called the default mode network that
gets activated when we get caught up in
craving it gets activated when we're
worrying about things it gets activated
when we get caught up in romantic love
you know like lusting after or pining
away about our loved one I think here we
can start to look at those experience or
qualities in the experience of quality
of that contraction that comes when
we're caught up with anxiety actually
registers in this default mode network
with increased activity this is what
Anderson Cooper showed so well it went
off the charts actually it was above you
know like we didn't even have this scale
to be able to reach that magnitude of
his so there you know that contraction
is something that we all can experience
directly and we can also experience the
opposite of the contraction which is
expansion and here it gets really
interesting and I actually give a TEDx
talk on flow there's a guy chick send me
hide chicks and mahai who is a
psychologist who described flow in the
70s in a book that he wrote where he
basically talks about it being
effortless selfless joyful timeless all
this stuff and the idea is you know this
this contraction quality it says okay
Here I am at
gives us an experiential marker of us
right in it's part of this self
referential brain Network whereas if you
take the if you start expanding and
loosening you know kind of expanding
that boundary and you get it so big
where you lose that sense of where you
end and where the rest of the world
begins you really get right into this
territory of flow that took some I
talked about and we're actually seeing
this in some of our real-time routes
feedback experiments where you know we
had an experienced meditator get into
flow in her posterior cingulate activity
that part of the default mode network
dropped precipitously so here I would
suggest we can use technology as a way
to give people feedback to help them
really get into that nuanced experience
of subtle forms of contraction in subtle
forms of expansion and then we can start
to calibrate our own experience and have
that be the experimental paradigm the
lab as well as the neurofeedback device
then we don't necessarily need to have
you know some expensive piece of
equipment to give us feedback once we've
calibrated our own experience so here I
think technology can be tremendously
helpful yet it can also be a hindrance
if we become reliant on it you know we
can't walk around every day with a
headset on our heads you know get a puss
you know with X Y or Z I think it's it's
it's a coming upon us to really have
this become part of our lived experience
mmm so I think that's really interesting
and I want to I want to dovetail that
with kind of the you know one of the
takeaways I get from from your both your
work in smoking cessation and in eating
cessation and using this notion of
curiosity as the superpower and we'll
get into that in just a little bit but
just the first little detour is a
prerogative of the host of the podcast
you know I always thought about you know
I've always been you know basically I
say I'm always on a diet and I'm always
hungry
in my whole life essentially and I don't
think it's necessarily a bad thing
because I think it forces me to be
disciplined think about when I'm
actually eating on a constant basis
rather than you know I have one of my
kids can he can eat like a whole you
know bag of Twizzlers and you know
he won't gain he'll lose weight and so
you know he's got this the one six-pack
and my side of the family actually has a
he has a 12-pack he was born with a six
pack in it and it went up from there and
there's umbilical cord there was a six
pack but you know my other other kids
are different and I'm different but I
always thought you know as one of the is
this an excuse tell me you know it's
your free psychology lesson a
psychiatric session I always justified
to myself well you know it should be
easier to give up smoking because you
don't need to smoke a little bit every
day to live but you need to eat and it's
always the middle ground rightly see
this in politics you see it and you
talked about this on your office hours
on your on your daily meditation moments
and just just advice during the corona
virus pandemic that we become addicted
and the more polarizing the better and
and and and I think you know for our
brains at least and for the media but
but you don't need news to survive you
could you could survive just fine but
you need food and I know wonder is it
truly harder to give up you know to lose
weight because you have to strike this
middle ground between these two poles
yes
and so this was this is how naive I was
when I was a young when I was a young
psychiatrist
we old the whipped to the couch yeah so
it turns out that smoking is actually
the hardest addiction to quit what seems
paradoxical to a lot of people but you
know they don't make movies about
smoking like they do about drinking or
using heroin or other things right and
people you know abused their kids and
you know they had a Marlboro and they go
and beat their kids or you know their
spouse or something right right so
smoking I when I did my first Studies on
smoking it was actually because I was
trying to tackle the hardest of
addictions to quit and here you know we
did a study where we've got five times
the gold standard you know quit rates in
in smoking cessation so it was loud
there's something to this and then so I
was like okay wow this works are the
hardcore addiction and then somebody
said you know I'm actually noticing I'm
changing my eating patterns based on
this and then my eyes popped out on my
head and said wait a minute and realize
that this is the same process for eating
yet with eating like you're pointing out
we have to eat to survive so I think in
one respect it is harder because you
can't just quit you can't just say I'm
never gonna do that again but the other
aspect is modern society has made food
I'm naming call it food made things
hyper palatable do make us want to you
know eat them and then they flaunt it
you know what is it ruffles or whatever
you bet you can't just eat wine find it
that way you know Joey I love my
favorite peer-reviewed journal the onion
that's right makes it Wikipedia yeah
they had a sort Dorito celebrates its
one millionth ingredient because you
know this is a completely manufactured
thing that's that's there to get us
addicted there's this great New York
Times article from 2013 I think it was
called the extraordinary science of
addicted junk addictive junk food I
encourage anyone that's interested in
this to read that I make my one of my
classes at Brown and have them read that
paper it's one of their favorite papers
to read in the semester but it just
highlights all the ways that the
industry is out there to get us addicted
to consuming calories right and some of
that you can even think of this
historically that because corn syrup is
so cheap because there's this corn
subsidy you know it even goes back to
that and so these conditions have been
set up where there's hyper power herbal
stuff that gets us to eat that over-over
healthy food so this is where the real
challenge came in for me was oh well can
we actually apply this to eating and it
turns out that our bodies are much
smarter than than our thinking brains
are our thinkin minds are in so when we
notice when we really pay attention we
start to see a number of patterns like
we'll eat food not because we're hungry
but because we're stressed right because
it makes us feel better it distracts us
one of my patients who is to add binge
on entire large pizzas in a single
sitting so she had full-blown binge
eating disorder and she do this 20 out
of 30 days a month she described it as I
would eat to numb myself so she would
you know she'd have an unpleasant
emotion that would come up and then she
would eat as a way to numb herself and
that numbing felt better than the
unpleasant emotion so we can actually
learn these habits I and so we learned
to eat not because we're hungry but
because we're stressed or sad or bored
or whatever and there's actually a term
for this called
daanyik hunger which means eating
because of emotions rather than
homeostatic hunger which is eating out
of actual physical hunger so there's all
of these things that come into play in
when in modern day when in in the past
it was just you know is this poison or
is this nutrient it was as simple as
that
yeah and actually going through it and
looking at well you know are there
things that we can you know impose on
ourselves those the technology to fight
against technology and as you're saying
you know these processed foods are
engineered and there's you know
socio-economic reasons why that's so and
different different imperatives towards
that one degree or another but yeah
that's it's I think you know what one
question I've had for you is kind of can
we pregame it like we have kids at home
and many of my listeners have kids is
there a way that you could sort of
inoculate your kids so that they don't
get bad habits they never smoked that
you know I I basically you know I'm
probably a terrible parent but I
basically have convinced my kids at
least the older three of them you know
that that drugs will kill you like any
kind of drug that's you know a Schedule
one narcotic just basically it kills
people it's awful you shouldn't try it
you know though needle drugs stay off at
blah blah blah you know I think maybe
it's overblown a little bit but I think
you know what if it does kind of trigger
this little you know audio recording in
their head to go off someday when I'm
not around
you know maybe they'll listen and I'm
wondering can can your tools can
curiosity can the dmn can the can the
habit loop hack can that be used to
inoculate kids to avoid the bad habit in
the first place yeah I think so I think
there are two elements to this did you
ever see the movie there's a documentary
called supersize me I saw some of it and
then I heard that there was some
controversy about how that was produced
but yeah go ahead
okay so I'll have a link to it yeah yeah
this story - that is this guy basically
says I'm gonna eat McDonald's every day
for a month and see what happens and I
at one point in the movie and I'm saying
this is a joke so don't don't do this
literally he said you know when I have
kids and we're driving by McDonald's
because he had talked about how McDonald
actually has a Playland specifically to
get kids to associate playing with
eating McDonald's you know and it's it's
kind of a nefarious like cereal has
prizes in it right now so he said every
time I Drive by McDonald I'm gonna punch
my kid but I think that's that's so
that's one way to do it I'm not
recommending people do what I was
whatever but he's pointing out it a
basic concept which is we associate X
with Y so what I would say is we can
actually hack this reward based learning
system but not in a way where we have to
torture ourselves or where we have to
punch ourselves or punch our kids but
just understanding the process actually
makes it relatively straightforward to
hack it and the way the way that it
works is that our brains are always
looking for what I call the the bigger
better offer the BBL okay the part of
the brain is called the orbital frontal
cortex that kind of stores and
determines reward values so for example
and I put a short animation together on
how to hack our minds for the reward
value of our mind or something I put
that out on my YouTube channel as well
folks want to look at that but basically
it talks about the difference between
broccoli and chocolate cake hmm so we
learned the reward value of chocolate
cake probably starting at a very young
age we go to a birthday party we
associate eating the cake with unit of
sugar and the fat with eating ice cream
presents friends lots of fun all that
stuff and then we reinforce that every
time we go to a birthday party so by the
time we're middle age our brain says hey
don't worry about the details cake is
good right just eat the cake so we
wonder why it's so hard not to eat cake
well it's because that reward guy he's
been sit down for such a long time so
the way to actually hack into that is
two things one is to help us see really
clearly how rewarding that food is right
in this moment so we've actually built a
tool right into our eat right now app
called the craving tool maybe you've
played with it or we have people imagine
eating the food when they have a craving
eat the food we have have them imagine
eating it so it can bring to mind their
current reward value how rewarding it is
right now it doesn't matter if they're
like well I really wanted
oh that's fine that tells us okay your
values this high then we have them pay
attention as they eat the as they eat
the food and if they eat oh if they
overeat or if they eat when they're not
hungry if they're even they're stressed
we asked them how content to you feel
afterwards and what they realize is it's
actually not that great to overeat or to
eat junk food or whatever and it
actually feels better to stop when I'm
full but then we just finished a study
on this we actually can model this out
mathematically these were score Laoag
nur models which are of reward value you
can actually see a significant reduction
in reward value close to zero within I
think it's within ten to twelve times of
people using this craving tool to
actually hack this system directly we
can model it mathematically which to me
is really fine but you know to to the
people to use the program they see this
as revolutionary because they realize
they don't have to force themselves not
to eat they don't have to force
themselves to go in these starvation
diets and in fact um start you know when
we get when we starve ourselves our body
says hey there's there must be a famine
I got to hold on to my calories so it's
even harder to lose weight that way mmm
so here we say forget about it and we
people they come to us and they're like
are you kidding because we say go ahead
and eat whatever you want
mmm we say just pay attention as you eat
because your body's pretty you know your
body knows how to regulate this stuff
you just have to pay attention to your
body mmm so starting that with it with
kids is something that you know could be
actually a way if not to completely
inoculate them but to at least make them
aware that it as early an age as
possible yeah and I would I will
highlight something really important
which is a lot of parents don't realize
that they're actually training their
kids like like they're you know like
flipper or where you know wild animals
are you're training to do tricks so you
know if it kids starts crying at the
grocery store and their parent says hey
V stop crying I'll give you a lollipop
you know suddenly they've just trained
their kids to scream for lollipops right
and that's it's not like they're doing
it on purpose
no of course like they have you know
that's training kids to like oh junk
food equals you know reward or you know
you eat all your eat all your dinner you
get some dessert you know that type of
thing so I think there are ways that we
can really look at the system and just
understand how this reward based
learning works so that parents can you
use their own wisdom to realize you know
help not perpetuate potential behaviors
that are gonna you know bite kids in the
ass down the road and they can teach
them Wow look how delicious this type
because actually healthy food tastes
pretty good I know there are a lot of
finicky kids out there but the more
there they just constantly eat hyper
palatable junk food the more their their
dopaminergic systems are going to drive
that eating actual taste and so I said
food palate right yeah so the joy of
eating can come in where you you know
you can explore all sorts of different
things cooking with the kids you know we
we got an air fryer which is just and I
actually just bought one for one of my
good friends he's got you know young
kids so they can they can like air fried
green beans in ways that you know and
have these really different yummy tastes
that are actually pretty healthy Wow
yeah so moving from young kids to older
kids and even adults I want to talk now
switch to a topic again it might be
primarily of interest to folks like you
and me I think I can translate over and
I mentioned this in some of the emails I
exchanged with you before we recorded
the podcast and that was about academic
issues and kind of mental health anxiety
etc so the first the first quote I want
to you know sort of get into I want to
talk about all the different things that
academics face because as I say I think
they can be applicable to people outside
of academia and leadership organizations
and and I do want to get to that in just
a little bit so the first thing I wanna
talk about is something you mentioned in
in your book the craving mind you
mentioned this sort of study done on
doctors that they reach a sort of
saturation with how much empathy they
can feel you call it empathy fatigue you
talk about medical students and the
amount of medical and kind of
diagnostician healthcare professionals
and just especially in this time they
become so saturated with
their grief or their own anxieties etc
that there aren't able to show the kind
of empathy that we would hope that our
health care you know practitioners
especially physicians would display can
you say something about that and if
there's anything that we can do about it
again while students are in medical
school or residency etc yeah I think
this is a really important thing to be
exploring so the first thing is if we
I'm gonna go back to this thing about if
we don't know how our minds work how are
we possibly possibly going to be able to
work with them here I think and the
theme I never learned anything about
empathy in medical school I think there
was just a sim that we're supposed to
empathize with our patient mm-hmm I
think that's changing now in current
medical schools which is great but the
idea is you know with empathy you're
supposed to put yourself in your
patients shoes and if your patients
suffering then you're gonna be suffering
if you're really putting yourself in
their shoes but we're only suffering if
we take their their own suffering
personally right and so the idea with
mindfulness is it can help us see
actually a different path which is when
we learn to not take things personally
which is really the root of what
mindfulness is about we can actually
step back we can be with suffering and
there's an opposite action that happens
instead of stepping back because it's
painful we step forward because we
actually feel the suffering of others
and we're not worried about protecting
ourselves or feeling bad ourselves does
that make sense yeah yeah and I think
it's an opportunity for physicians to
demonstrate and I'll get into that in a
second but yet did you want to finish up
that that thought well I was just gonna
say we did a study with our anxiety app
if you I don't know if you're gonna get
to that but we found that we got a you
know there's a strong correlation
between physician anxiety and burnout
there are a lot of reasons for that both
individual and institutional but we did
as book pilot study we just published it
a couple of weeks ago where we just look
to see if physicians would use this on
running anxiety up and we've got a 57
percent reduction in clinically
validated exoti scores and we got a 50%
reduction in certain aspects of burnout
because there are individual aspects
that are highly correlated with anxiety
such as cynicism and people realize oh
this is how this is me getting caught up
in this
loop around being cynical it's actually
burning energy that's not helping
anybody and just making my life more
miserable very good yeah I'd actually
had a conversation about a week ago with
dr. Peter Diamandis who like you you
know hasn't intubated anybody and you
know since he was in medical school but
but he was talking about the the
possibility of medicine being you know
if not largely perhaps mostly outsourced
to the cloud devices that I have in the
room whose names I can't say but Niels
Aloysius or somebody who's in the room
or you know or Chirag E or somebody like
that where you'll be you know because of
classic you know view of the doctor in
the old days is the house call and the
doctor sitting by the and now it's the
doctors on a computer and the patients
on an iPhone they're not even looking at
each other and I wonder if you know
teaching doctors these tools as you're
doing could help you know obviate some
of the advantages that quite frankly AI
does have over humanity in that you know
as patients talking the AI could be
searching every single you know person
who's ever reported this in the history
of you know digitized health records and
that's huge but the the the you know the
chatbot can't replace the human touch
but if the doctor him or herself is not
acting with that most human of qualities
empathy and loving kindness etc then
then what serves to differentiate them
so I think that is a huge thing I wanna
you know and a benefit to to you know
medical students and people that take
advantage of and we'll have links to
like to that to the overcoming anxiety
as well as the other apps I want to turn
now maybe to it yeah I could just
mention something quickly which is what
I really see ideally is a in
augmentation of a medical care where
physicians can move back into the places
that they probably drew them to become
doctors in the first place which is the
care of their patients and so they if
they can have augmentation strategies
where they've got ia I on the background
helping them with their differential
diagnosis and looking up all the
cross-reactivity for different
medications which we can't possibly
store in our brains right that could be
a great tool that could then
a sub to actually be with our patients
and you know have that compassionate
care because compassion has been shown
repeatedly to be a critical aspect of
medicine it's not just a you know take
this pill and then you're fixed mmm huge
aspect of the personal component to that
as well and that might actually free us
up once we figure out this whole
electronic medical record conundrum and
all this you know all these other
regulatory things that are keeping
physicians from actually doing you know
being a doctor right
I really see down the road a really nice
blend between that personal and that
caring component and the you know it's
just called the AI component that can
help augment all of the all of the
different informational aspects mm-hmm
very good so sticking with academia
let's take a step back in the
educational career of somebody who goes
to college and has to face the first
kind of step in the wrong and the
academic ladder is you know is getting
accepted to a college or a graduate
school or medical school and worrying
about rejection and and then if you're
accepted once you get there you have
sort of the opposite you know the fear
of being an imposter so-called imposter
syndrome can you talk about that in the
academic setting and you know what kind
of you know tools that people can use to
cope with these twin you know
diametrically opposed fears that one
with him yeah I I think they're I mean
they're this happens at every step of
the game I remember in high school like
my college counselor told me that I
would never get into Princeton and I was
so pissed off that I applied there early
just to piss her off
and that's why I ended up going to
school so you know I think this happened
so much you know where it's like we get
you know and then I we get someone we're
like Oh everybody's smarter than I am I
was like so I think just knowing our
minds again is gonna take us really
really far here if we can notice that
we're caught up in these anxieties these
worry habit loops like oh everybody else
is smarter than I am you know
there they used to do this I think it
was at MIT where they would say you know
their freshman assembly it's a state up
if you were the valedictorian of your
salutat or any of your class and like
everybody stood up except one person who
probably was mortified and traumatized
for math for the rest of their life you
know so I think here if we can really
tap into and see that our minds are
actually you know this is this old
survival mechanism that's just trying to
help us survive but it's kind of getting
a little off course and we're actually
tripping ourself up that way it can
really help us take a step back and take
us a long way toward healing because
worrying that we're not good enough is
gonna actually make our thinking brain
go offline and make it harder for us to
see that we are actually good enough and
it's gonna make it harder for us to be
able to bring out our natural talents so
here's where you mentioned this earlier
but we can get into this more this is
where the super power of curiosity comes
in so you know we talked about seeing
how unrewarding old habits are like
overeating or whatever but we didn't
actually talk about that bigger better
offer and I think in academics curiosity
is that bigger better offer it feels
better so for example if somebody has a
craving to eat food what is what feels
better craving your curiosity you know
curiosity feels better so even if
somebody's trying to break a bad habit
they can they can start to bring in
curiosity itself but we can also do this
when we've got when we're falling into
bad habit patterns around self judgment
or self doubt or you know shame or
feeling like an impostor we can get
curious right in the moment and ask our
says oh what does this feel like like
not why am I feeling this way but what
does this feel like in my body does it
feel more you know X Y or Z on the right
side or the left side and so we can
start to get curious right in that
moment about what those sensations feel
like in that curiosity itself helps us
unwind from those old habit loops right
in the moment mmm yeah and I think
that's that's you know something that's
so endemic to the academic you know kind
of ladder that we climb those of us that
stay in academia but again you can
translate you know this to any other
field whether it's you know making
partner in a law firm or what
you I think you know for me one thing
that's really come up a lot in you know
as an academic as a as a faculty member
is sort of again these two different
opposing emotions or reactions which is
on one side you know we have this
craving to be attributed you may not
know this but you've probably heard of
the h-index right yep because I was
actually conceived of one of my physics
colleagues here
Jorge Hirsch in the physics department
so H is for Hirsch and it's sort of this
metric that's supposed to track not just
a number of times a single paper has
been cited but the kind of corpus of
your academic citations that you might
want to explain to the listeners but you
know citations are like the ultimate you
know thumbs up on Facebook or like on
instagrams or whatever and it's and it
becomes addicted I have to say you know
that you want to be attributed and
credited because you know we don't
really get into academia for the money
but but on the other hand I think you
know certainly having ideas and and
having the attention that we feel or
ideas or do I think that's one whole
again these are a dichotomy here the
other side is like you know fear of
being wrong and fear of failure that we
have or what if you know this thing that
I've been working on is taken out of
context or if it's misattributed or if
I'm wrong I get a study and I had to
retract it III know that feeling you
know and or how to reinterpret its
results so how do we balance that and
and again this could be you know another
sign of something that applies well
outside of academia and the law firm or
a real estate firm you know whatever
wanting to get credit for successes but
also avoid blame on the other hand is
there a craving or addictive component
to that as well yeah I think there is so
here you know just and there have been
studies for example with likes on
Instagram showing that that this getting
a bunch of likes activates both the
reward centers as well as the
self-referential parts of the brain and
like you're pointing out you know with
academia it's the h-index or the number
of citations that we have or you know
whatever they're a bunch of different
ways that we measure ourselves and
measure our peers in terms of you know
oh how successful are they
you know you don't have to ask them you
know it's not about salaries but it's
about you know how many citations do you
know right so I think that you know we
see that aspect in academia just like we
see it all over the place where in
modern day we've you can quantify this
stuff like we've never been able to
before you know I don't know when the
h-index came out but it hasn't been
around for twenty years it's it's
relatively new same thing is true with
social communication we see you know
teenagers sitting next to each other
texting each other rather than looking
at each other in the face and it's a
museum right right well and it's
interesting because you you know our
brains don't like uncertainty I did a
YouTube video on a couple of things
around uncertainty and anxiety but the
idea is that our brains really you know
that uncertainty drives us to get
information because information helps us
survive and our brains would much rather
have something definitive than ambiguous
and so if you look at somebody's face
and you look at their body posture and
all this stuff there's there's a lot of
uncertainty in terms of what is it what
were they really mean by that what was
that tone of voice was that angry was
that ink you know inquisitive and then
you could compare that to just getting
50 likes on Facebook or Instagram you
know exactly where you stand and then
you can compare that to everybody else
it's a it's a you know they exist court
you know they basically normalized this
the scale so that everybody knows
exactly what the what it is and you can
actually put a monetary value on I think
you can actually I think it's true you
can buy likes on Instagram what used to
be able to so you can actually there's a
monitor you can determine how much alike
is worth whereas that's really different
than just having a conversation with
somebody and having to actually you know
have that ambiguity and be with that
ambiguity and learn from it right and I
think you know just coming back as we
wind up a little bit and you have a few
more minutes to go judge a few more okay
great I want to talk about the opposite
sort of scenario where people are anti
curious we see this in science of people
you know denialist and certain
scientific paradigms or sure
events and our orders hostility in the
case of you know well-meaning
academicians to different paradigm
shifts in academia is there you know
evolutionary or some advantage to that I
mean you could see the evolutionary
advantage you talked about in the book
of all you hear rustling in the woods in
the savanna of Africa you know those
that were curious what's causing that
survived and propagated their genetic
material whereas those that didn't you
know more probably on a lion food or I
don't know what happens in the savanna
but but but you get the point so is
there any of why do we have people that
are anti curious or suppression or
denialist in some sense why do you think
that is
well I think this goes back to this
uncertainty thing you know certainty
feels good and them and when something
feels really good we try to perpetuate
it over and over and over and over and
so you know we see this in people you
know reach a certain salary and a
certain type of you know job that is
secure it's harder for them to say I'm
gonna take a risk and try a different
job or I'm gonna you know I'm gonna try
this or I'm gonna try this is really
scary because you don't know if you're
gonna succeed or fail so I think there's
an aspect of that even around ideas
where you know people can get a test
that are on ideas so there were two
well-known physicist you probably know
these so who was it that said how does
physics progress one funeral at a time
yeah max max planck funk you guys yeah
so plonk says this and then there's I'm
Stein who says you should never lose
your holy curiosity you know it that's
how much reverence he had for curiosity
so I think what they're both planning to
is how when we become still to fight
when we become attached to our own ideas
we we are no longer scientists and this
is for this goes for everyone you know
it's not just science but I think
science really exemplifies this as soon
as we are so attached to our own ideas
that we have to defend them literally to
our death we've we've halted the
progress of science because then people
have to wait for us to die sometimes
literally before they can say well what
about this you know because they don't
have a lot of voice or don't have as
many likes on their you know proverbial
Facebook or a Facebook feed
so I think yeah I think that's really
the aspect of it is this it's this old
survival mechanism trying to say hey
make sure things don't change when in
reality the only unchanging thing is
change itself hmm mm-hmm very
interesting yeah I think it's it's
fascinating when I look at those quotes
or you know Einstein another one of his
famous quotes you know I am nothing but
passionate I'm just a passionately
curious etc and he also said you know
imagination is more important than
knowledge which I like as the
co-director of the arthur c-- clark
center for human imagination but i hope
if my you know neurosurgeon god forbid
ever has to surge i hope yes you know or
she has some knowledge you know not just
i'm gonna be really imaginative when i
go and do this surgery and brian's you
know lamebrain i want to finish up the
before we turn to the last segment which
is standard amongst all of our podcasts
but i want to finish up with a question
from the audience who asked this of you
about applying your ideas to the
workplace and getting beyond the happy
talk which he calls employee development
theater and he says the bottom line is
that most workplaces are all about the
bottom line at the organizational level
there's profit and perpetuation of the
company or personal individual
advancement even at the expense of
others ie there's a lot of duplicity
inauthenticity between the company and
the customer between employees and
themselves and in most organizations and
the employees that hire them we don't
give much thought to how we might be
manipulating or taking advantage of
other people but but using notions of
self-esteem etcetera can it be
reconciled short of quitting I guess
he's talking about maybe a hostile
workplace or ways to maybe isolate
compartmentalize without being you know
without being completely introverted
shut off from a company are there tools
that you know we can beyond the kind of
meta loving-kindness you know which to
him would might feel inauthentic other
ways that that he can sort of you know
deal with these using techniques that
you might have developed in the
workplace yeah what a great question and
so here I would say yes absolutely and I
think some of this is you know there's
this whole thing called delay
discounting are you familiar with this
No so basically the
to work I think one pick was when the
folks that led this showing that we
would prefer an immediate reward over a
delayed reward which basically you know
gets uncertainty I don't know if I'm
gonna get this from word later and so
we'll actually forego a greater reward
that we're gonna get later for an
immediate reward is this like loss
aversion or relative to that it's I
think it's slightly it's related but
slightly different so basically the
simple way to explain or give an example
would be you know I'm gonna give you you
know if I were to offer you 12 dollars
in a week versus ten dollars today what
would you take Yeah right yeah I mean
I'm I'm all about making sure you're
still solvent so it might take today's
today's finances exactly even though you
know that's a much better pretty good
you know weeks you know that's a good
interest rate for the way that's delay
discounting and I think that's our
brains at play you know the work place
where there could be this immediate
response where we're like oh this I'm
gonna get this immediately you know
right away right and we're not actually
looking at the old you know what the at
the detriment of that and so um I think
we can actually turn this on its head
and really ask ourselves okay you know
if I'm if I'm given this this choice for
an immediate reward how rewarding is
this you know if I if I could step on my
co-workers head to get slightly ahead
now there's this excitement quality it
comes to this that's that through this
whole you know evolutionary process but
at the same time we could look at
cooperation what that actually look like
what's it feel like if we're truly
cooperative hmm what I would suggest is
it it feels better and actually leads to
longer-term benefits for everyone it's
just that it's kind of scary if we're
like well that guy's gonna screw me if
I'm nice to him so I better screw him
first you know that type of thing Wow so
here I think we generally wore what it
feels like and practice it you know
what's it like to be kind to others and
does that actually help us feel better
right now in the workplace does it lead
to a better workplace environment
especially if we're in a leadership
position and does that actually
this better work product down the road I
would argue it helps people be more
efficient more effective more rested
happier all these other things that are
actually gonna make a much better
business that'll spill out into
customers were the that was a really
nice person to interact with as compared
to well that guys burned down right
jaded and an introverted are not great
combinations okay I want to finish up
with what I call the into the impossible
final five these are questions I ask all
the all the guests if you can be as
short as possible I know you you don't
have an infinite amount of time nor do
any of us the first ones about your book
and about books in general I kind of see
books is like a DNA passed on throughout
our species and I'm gonna be
interviewing Carl Sagan the late Carl
Sagan's daughter Sasha later this week
and and she quotes from her father about
the magic of books that this is like
time travel basically so speaking in
that vein about time trouble and you
could just answer a simple one sentence
answer personally would you rather have
a hundred people read read the craving
mind one year from now or one person
read the craving mind a hundred years
from now
longevity versus immediacy forgetting
about book sales yeah the book in a
hundred years where will it cost a
hundred times more than it does now I
yeah a hundred people read it one year
from now definitely alright and if you
were to choose if you how to choose a
group of people to read this book would
it rather would you rather have them be
people that are skeptical perhaps
doubters not hostile obviously it's not
going to sit down read it or would you
rather it be people that are open or you
know intrigued by it sort of already
fans of what you're what you're
producing well I would love to see
skeptics who are not so stuck in their
ruts of thinking that aren't there are
open to any new ideas but I'd much
rather have skeptics who who really look
at things critically than like a fan
base read this great and yeah see who
has sort of a guarded optimist you're a
very cheerful person you always put me
in a good mood whenever I see you on the
app or online what are you pessimistic
about there's got to be things you're
very pessimistic about what are they
that's a good question what am i
pessimistic about it whether we as a
human race will wake up fast enough not
to destroy our planet okay fair enough
and the last two questions ones very
easy and one's a little bit harder but
so this podcast is named after Arthur C
Clarks a second law his first law was
that for any sufficiently advanced
society technology it's
indistinguishable from magic
and his second law was the only way to
find out what's possible is to venture
beyond a little bit into the impossible
and that's where we get our name from
but the question I have for you now is
what did you think as a 20 year old as a
30 year old as a young person you
thought it was impossible but now that
you went into the impossible now feels
like you want to give shake that 20-year
old version of Judd and tell him it's
going to be ok what what seemed
impossible that you ended up
accomplishing I would have to say an
understanding of my mind you know
certainly have a long way to go but you
know I
it just seemed like such a black box and
I was completely at the whims of my
urges mmm boy it's actually relatively
simple I and it's so good and then the
last question I have for you is and I
suspect it'll be in the affirmative but
what you do as a scientist as a as a
professor etc is that something that
they're components are sort of equal
between intrinsically specific to
yourself or other things that you can
learn that you can teach that you can
mentor so that basically you know a
young version of me could be as
successful as you are and what you did
the I think the one thing I would mentor
people in is curiosity and I think
that's both intrinsic and measurable so
that's what I would say you know never
never lose that holy curiosity may we
all aspire to - what did Einstein say
you know I'm
curiosity over knowledge or whatever his
very yeah that's right it's I'm nothing
if not passionately curious
yes let's train everybody to get
addicted to curiosity yeah and maybe
imagination here at the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination that makes
a nice plug for us and i want to give
you a chance to plug anything that
you're interested in promoting you have
the daily updates and anxiety and talk
about your apps your twitter your
website sure so folks can find me two
easiest places or the youtube channel
which is dr dr ju d and same for the
website which has all the apps on it as
well as a bunch of free resources we put
animations out there to help people
understand the neuroscience behind this
stuff even some free health care
providers courses we've even put out a
free app called breathe by dr judge for
people that just want to learn some
basics around mindfulness and then i'm
also on twitter at Judd brewer Ju d PR e
WV are great and we'll have links to all
those and I try to thank you for this
free 90 minute session that's you've
provided for me and for you know tens of
thousands of other people hopefully
they'll be listening and watching this
Judd it's been a delight following you
online for many years you're great to
hear your voice and actually responding
to me when I scream at it not I don't
scream at you and so it's a wonderful
service that you provided thank you for
the the updates everything you do it's
done with such graciousness and
generosity of spirit that I speak on
behalf of the whole audience and just
expressing our great gratitude to you
well thank you it's been a pleasure any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable imagine
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe comment
share and review for a chance to win a
free copy of our most recent guest
newest book send a screenshot of your
review to info at imagine CST edu we
appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes into the impossible is a
production of the arthur c-- clark
center for human imagination at UC san
diego in the division of physical
sciences directed by hair at very Brian
heating and Patrick Alban produced by
Stewart Valle go